Next let's look at the material parameter collections. Sometimes you'll see this
referred to as MPC if you see any naming conventions but essentially we'll
discuss what is a material parameter collection and also how to get them
set up inside of Unreal so you can control them through something like
Sequencer. So a material parameter collection is essentially just a system
that is used to control whole parameters of items in a material all
at once. So a material parameter can be loaded in the sequencer, it can be
animated for sweeping control so maybe we want a certain parameter that changes
the color of a light or makes the material on a flower per cup or change
color depending on the time of day or just some kind of control that we want
to have over many assets all at once. Material parameter collections can be
the solution for this. So to create these and we'll go in the step-by-step
of how to do this in a few moments here but just so you understand the
workflow I will cover it right now. So we can right-click in the content
browser, go to material parameter collection under the material section
once you've created it double click it and then when opened you can choose
whether you need a scalar parameter or a vector parameter. So there are your two
options there. Scalar is just going to be one value, vectors are going to be three.
Scalars are typically used to control an amount of effects such as
roughness or opacity or brightness or something like that and can be used to
pull amounts from other systems whereas vectors are more used to help control
color and can be linked to the values. So when you have the material
parameter collection created you can drag it into material you want to
control and then you can decide what parameters you want to control based on
that material parameter collection you created. So you can hook up to the
corresponding material nodes and the output and again we'll do this in a
moment here so this is just to give you the high-level knowledge and then we
can because it's a content asset inside your content browser you can
actually drag and drop it into sequencer. Now you can load the
parameter that you want from here with the drop down and then now all the
the keys that you want the values say you have a vector value that you want
to control you can actually control it directly through sequencer which is a
really great way to control the values of many assets all in one
instance here. So we're back in our engine here and we've loaded up the
npc underscore material map here and just to show you the end result of what
we're looking for we've got our material parameter selected and now when
we play it you can see throughout the scene we're increasing the
snow coverage in this instance so you can see that just by panelling
here we can have a global impact on our scene and it allows us to control
many different properties whether it be the water opacity, wetness intensity,
roughness, low and high we're just keying all these values inside a
sequencer so that we can have the desired result on the scene in a global
way. So to create your material parameter collection as we said you go to the
content browser we can right-click here we can go to materials and we
can go to the material parameter collection second from the bottom here and if you
select that you can call it something like npc underscore whatever you want
your effect to be. In this instance we've called it the environment effects
so if I now load this up you'll see that we have this window here and I've
added an element here so as we said in in the slides you can add scalar
parameters or vector parameters. Vector again is the the three values which
generally could be used to control color or some kind of coordinate values which
is the XYZ but we've got four scalar parameters so we've
just added these four times and we've got these values here so we've got
the default values all set 0 100 0 0 and you've got these parameter names
which we'll be using in our material to control these certain parameters and
all these names are things to just reference from the material into the
sequencer what it is that we're controlling so these names aren't
actually doing anything right now but when used in the material they'll be
then able to be keyed inside of that sequencer file. So this is the setup
of the material parameter collection and this is just to control the
environment effects. So then if we hop over into our content browser again
and we have our MPC material setup you can double click this here and you'll
see exactly what's going on here with our material parameter collection so
we've got the environment effects and you can just drag and drop this in
based on your content browser so if I gave myself a bit more real estate
here again when in doubt if you're trying to use an asset somewhere you
can just drag and drop it in so we've got our material parameter collection you
can just drag and drop that in and it says none right now if I just
maximize this but you'll see that we've got our collection here you can just
right click and create a material parameter collection as well or you can
drag and drop it in because then it'll automatically assign the asset so this
isn't actually it's not got any information other than the names in
there and the values that you want to use but in combined with the material
this is the power so we can drop down now we've got these four options and
those four options are because we added these four here so if I add a
fifth here and call it hello or something like this and just save it
and I might need to resave this but let's just look for this extra option
here so let's do its thing it'll save and then if you drop down you'll
see hello there so this is all that's going on we've just got values inside
the material parameter we've selected the global roughness value here the wet
intensify and the roughness and this is essentially now able to be used in
conjunction inside of this material so that say we want to dial up the
wetness intensity that goes into the multiply and into a specular and so
we're controlling values in here we have some default values set and then
in this sequence of file now what we can do is in this simple animation I've got
it open here all we did was keyed in these values so we're starting at 0 0 1
1 here and then we dial it up and this is these are the values that you
want from your material parameter collection the values that work for your
scene so essentially we're just hand keying new values inside a sequencer
so just to show you how that works so if I just go ahead and delete this
from here and just drag out my sequences so I can see my material
parameter collection I'll just type in NPC and I just want to bring in this
environment effects that we just created so we can put that in there and
you'll see that it comes in as the material parameter collection with
nothing keyed yet so then if we just pin the sequencer to the bar and then
we just want to add our parameters that we created before so again that
hello is just temporary so we want to add the water opacity and then we could
just drop down here they'll start being added here I'll just delete this key
yours may not have come with a value there but we'll just add zero there so
I'll just add a key and then I'll go to get my wetness and that's just
added a key there and then I'll add the low one as well and then the
higher one and then all we want to do is drag to somewhere in our scene and
just dial in these values so whatever the value works for you but in this
specific material setup I believe water was at one so we see the water
come in wetness was at one so I'm just gonna hit one there and hit
enter and because I am down at the end of my sequencer you'll see these
values being dialed in I believe the the low value was 0.3 drag that in
and then the roughness high was 0.2 I believe and you'll see it just scrub in
like this and you'll see our values coming on and we can also change how
the curves look if we want by using the curve graph but so if you want it
working in like a linear way or just more of a constant or however you want
essentially the curves to look so plenty of control there but hopefully
that gives you a good overview of how material parameter collections work
inside of Unreal Engine there are also some great resources online that you
can dig into so the documentation for material parameter collections can be
found at this URL for you to dig into and just learn more about what
material parameter collections are and how you can use them in your projects